una de las posibilidades que brinda el
trabajo de historiar la ley es el poder
leer y tener esta facilidad de adquirir
archivos en los cuales podamos
relacionarlos con documentos sumamente
importantes pero además demasiado
íntimos como es la relación epistolar y
en este caso particular me refiero a la
correspondencia propia de esa estela
ramírez un anarquista del período previo
a la revolución mexicana que en los
últimos dos meses estado inmersa leyendo
parte de esta correspondencia y de esta
obra y viene mucho a colación lo que
vamos a platicar el día de ahora acerca
de los derechos culturales resistencia y
poder frente al estado porque mencionaba
una oración que me pareció demasiado
prudente pero a la vez demasiado cíclica
en cuanto a la situación actual que
estamos viviendo y ella decía
necesitamos atravesar con muchísima
calma esta crisis para generar
nuevamente las posibilidades de una
regeneración
obviamente hacia un guiño a este diario
regeneración he publicado a partir de
también me llama mucho la atención como
esta clase de frases a pesar de que ya
pasaron más de 100 años siguen siendo
sumamente vigentes en la cotidianidad y
sobre todo en lo que actualmente
atravesamos la pandemia del cob y 19 que
ha sido como un tema que todos hemos
tocado aquí por lo brutal del impacto
pues si atacó a varios sectores a nivel
mundial pero yo me quiero referir
específicamente en esta ocasión a uno
que es el sector cultura la comunidad
cultural se vio brutalmente afectada por
esto porque exhibió que no existían las
formas de seguridad social y de atención
a la salud pública en méxico además la
falta de acceso a derechos fundamentales
como la vivienda y los alimentos esto
quiere decir que no existen los
mecanismos jurisdiccionales para acceder
a estos derechos pero además puso el
debate sobre las formas de poder
adquirir estos derechos mediante nuevas
reformas de mecanismos legales que no se
nos pudieran dar uno de los factores
importantes de los derechos culturales
que es la dignidad humana si bien es
cierto que la dignidad humana es el
pilar
también es cierto que nos han generado
durante todos estos años las condiciones
para hacer las propicias esto totalmente
de acuerdo con lo que más tiene que ver
el asunto de la legislación cultural con
la protección de la creación artística y
la libertad creativa de ahí la
importancia de que vayan vinculados con
derechos de primera generación como lo
es la atención a la vida y a la salud
pública a partir de toda esta situación
que exhibió la falta de acceso a estos
derechos en el 2012 la suprema corte de
justicia de la nación emitió una tesis
aislada en el cual decía que el estado
debería garantizar la libre emisión
protección y circulación del derecho a
la cultura en condiciones de libertad
creativa y de protección sin embargo
este fundamento que es el resultado de
un amparo indirecto que promovieron la
sociedad de mexicanos audiovisuales de
cine en el 2011 sentó un precedente
constitucional importante porque por
primera vez el estado respondía cuáles
eran sus obligaciones frente a la teoría
cultural
en el 2009 esta misma reforma más
importante que se hizo en materia de
cultura en el artículo cuarto párrafo no
me no pues ya nos daba las bases
importantes de cómo tenían que situarse
los derechos culturales estos que son
inherentes a todas las personas sin
condición de discriminación igualdad
dignidad humana y sobre todo perspectiva
de género era muy importante
hacer hincapié en esto porque al igual
que los otros derechos humanos que
quizás son más visibles pero no por eso
menos importantes también tenían los
principios de universalidad
indivisibilidad e interdependencia a
partir de todas estas recorrido que se
hace pues la protección de estos
derechos también está no solamente en
esa carta sino en lo que conocemos como
la carta declaración de derechos humanos
en la cual está conformada por tres y
por una muy específica que me gustaría
resaltar la declaración universal de los
derechos humanos por supuesto de 1948 el
pacto internacional de los derechos
civiles y políticos de 1966 el pacto
internacional de derechos económicos y
culturales
y yo agregaría una cuarta que es la
recomendación relativa al artista de
1980 y eso porque es importante porque
por primera vez en un marco normal
normativo se definía el concepto de
artista que significaba ser artista
frente a todo este ordenamiento y esta
maraña de lo que era la legislación todo
muy bien hasta ahí de queda el marco
jurídico que tenemos en méxico que
tenemos a nivel internacional pero qué
pasa en la realidad en esta cotidianidad
de a pie de todas y todos nos levantamos
vamos al trabajo vamos a la escuela como
nos atraviesan los derechos culturales a
partir de ahí quiero poner un ejemplo
bien específico porque a mi parecer
tiene la misma relevancia en cuanto al
derecho a la cultura y tiene que ver con
el extractivismo y la apropiación
cultural que se hace de estos derechos y
en situaciones como muy básicas y en
esto la recomendación general de la
comisión de derechos humanos en el 2019
dejó claro que la falta de acceso
procedimental es decir de que no hay
acceso a derechos básicos como salud
pública vivienda techado alcantarillado
en las comunidades y en los pueblos
indígenas limita el acceso a la cultura
y el acceso a la cultura en cuestiones
como demasiado básicas que podemos
hablar no solamente de disciplinas
artísticas como el teatro la literatura
la danza sino a quienes también elaboran
procesos culturales a partir de lo que
conocen como las artesanías o sea eso es
sumamente fundamental porque ahí viene
también un asunto de extraviar y de
apropiarnos otras otras comunidades
sobre lo que se produce y es un ejemplo
similar de lo que pasa con los recursos
naturales así como los derechos
ambientales y hay defensores de derechos
ambientales para proteger el patrimonio
material de cada una de estas tierras
también hay defensores de derechos
culturales para evitar que el
extractivismo y la apropiación caigan
sobre ellos
esto es brutal porque podemos poner
muchísimos ejemplos pero es uno de los
que me llegó a mí demasiado puntual fue
que hace dos años recorrimos la montaña
de guerrero
una persona de la comunidad de
metlatónoc y llegabas a mezcla tono para
que no conozcan este municipio está más
o menos a 15 horas de acá y después de
esas 15 horas caminaba es y vas en coche
tres horas más y había un señor que si
hoy viviera tendría 101 años él era
portador de cinco danzas esas cinco
danzas eran los terrones y variaciones
de la danza de los diablos porque
también la montaña tiene su propia danza
de los diablos distinta a la de la costa
chica y nos comentaba obviamente
apoyados por un traductor que solamente
había logrado trasladar dos de esas tan
zas es decir tres con su muerte se iban
a perder y ese es parte también del del
patrimonio inmaterial que tenemos como
mexicanos y sobre todo en particular
como guerrerenses qué pasa con estas
noticias que parecieran como bastante
aisladas de nosotros y que no son la
misma repercusión que hablar de mineras
o de extracción de recursos naturales es
parte también de eso y hay que
es fundamental no solamente decir el
problema está ahí y qué es lo que
hacemos lo que observado en los últimos
años creando espacios también para la
difusión del arte y la cultura es que lo
que ha sostenido el derecho de acceso a
esta a la cultura no solamente en
guerreros sino a nivel nacional es las
pequeñas células de comunidades
organizadas que son las que brindan
estos servicios en condiciones de
igualdad y de no discriminación porque
también hay que hacer bastante francas
hay una un sesgo de género de clase y de
origen étnico en cuanto al acceso es
decir estamos acostumbrados a que exista
la alta cultura
y existan las tradiciones las
tradiciones de dominio popular lo cual
también ha hecho como esta separación de
que solamente existen lugares
sacralizados en los cuales se adquiere y
que solamente ciertas personas pueden
acceder a ellos y no lo importante de
los derechos culturales es que éstos se
den en estas condiciones de igualdad de
no discriminación de perspectiva de
género
y de dignidad humana qué pasa con esto
qué pasa con las organizaciones que se
dedican a esta protección de los
derechos culturales es bien sencillo lo
que ellos hacen es vivir también de las
gestiones no solamente institucionales
sino las que se propician entre
cooperativas que pueden dar fundamento
no solamente económico sino también
legal a las cosas que están sucediendo
en cada una de esas en acapulco tenemos
la experiencia de un festival que
comenzó con ser un encuentro muy muy
pequeño en un encuentro muy muy limitado
en el cual los primeros tres años se
tuvo bastante apoyo de las personas
digamos de los vecinos de las escuelas
pero no de gestiones que pudieran dar la
posibilidad de que creciera actualmente
es un festival nacional pero no es como
un asunto de bueno vamos a hablar de
este modelo sino de algo bien importante
este festival lo que hizo fue sacralizar
el lado el dogma que del fomento de la
cultura era aburrido y era tedioso lo
que se hizo también es esto que
tanto en los discursos institucionales
acerca de vamos a resarcir el tejido
social el tejido social no se resarce
con palabras no se resalta con
legislación y en eso no podemos ser
ingenuas a pesar de que conocemos un
marco teórico y conocemos las
deficiencias de estos mecanismos no se
soluciona desde ahí qué pasa con esta
clase de festivales y no solamente en
acapulco sino en las siete regiones que
componen el estado de guerrero que da la
posibilidad de poder crear lugares en
los cuales el espacio público se
convierta en algo en una apropiación
para las personas para las familias que
puedan tener acceso también a esos
talleres en estas condiciones que me
cansaba de repetir de no discriminación
y de igualdad ese es la forma en la que
las comunidades organizadas permiten que
se permite este acceso es uno de los
avances más importantes no desde las
instituciones sino desde la comunidad
organizada y aquí viene mucha colación
algo que nos parece fundamental que es
el territorio cuerpo y lengua que son
tres binomios que van muy muy de la mano
con lo que tiene que ver con
el acceso a estos derechos y es que si
atendemos a los datos del inali en
mexico se hablan 69 lenguas cuatro de
ellas en guerrero de las 33 que se
hablaban desde el siglo 16 slam agua de
la musgo el chiapaneco y el mixteco por
supuesto que con todas sus variantes sin
embargo este trinomio que yo les estoy
proponiendo de cuerpo lengua y
territorio es fundamental porque también
es parte de resarcir y de proteger el
ejercicio de la memoria oral y escrita y
eso no solamente en las disciplinas de
danza de teatro sino también en lo que
conocemos como las tradiciones populares
que son en las que su mayoría se
sostiene es parte de la identidad y la
pluriculturalidad en esta tesitura lo
que que es lo que podemos hacer y qué es
lo que estamos implementando a nivel
local que también ha sido una de las
cosas que hemos criticado no solamente
por lo limitante que es el derecho sino
por la necesidad de que también sean
escuchados a partir de eso la política
no es privativa de los partidos su
génesis concierne a los ciudadanos
y ahí es donde radica la presentación y
la organización de grupos en los cuales
se presenten iniciativas para reformar
la ley desde las necesidades y desde la
escucha y el diálogo de estas
comunidades eso es fundamental y vital
así como la recuperación y la
preservación de archivos históricos que
nos puedan mostrar otras formas
hegemónicas de la historia que habían
sido reducidas obviamente a la figura y
a la visibilidad masculina el guerrero
somos un estado de resistencia y de
formas históricas inigualables porque
también las mujeres desde ahí han podido
luchar por la autonomía y por la
visibilidad de estos derechos me encanta
mucho esto que dice lorena captar de que
las mujeres estamos ahí al filo del
territorio siempre poniendo el cuerpo y
eso también constituye un acto histórico
y no solamente histórico sino parte
fundamental de poder acceder a esta
cultura por parte de las mujeres y bueno
podría mencionar muchísimas en este
recorrido pero me sale a colación cuatro
fundamentales que tienen que ver con la
edición de diarios feministas
a finales del siglo 19 como laureana
bryant asko como las mujeres de la
revolución social y la revolución
agraria que me encanta llamarlas así
para desprender las de esa otredad de
los caudillos no son las zapatistas no
son las villistas son las mujeres de la
revolución social agraria y electoral
como juana castro castro vázquez como el
odia campusano como ávila
nájera que además cumplen una función
fundamental y eso viene mucho a colación
con lo que voy a mencionar porque
estamos en una escuela y en ellas en las
maestras en el magisterio es donde se ha
sostenido gran parte de este derecho y
de este acceso ay me parece que tenemos
una labor muy importante desde los
espacios comunitarios y donde podemos
hacer visible la llamada
interdependencia de los derechos de otra
de otra naturaleza como los civiles los
políticos los económicos con los
ambientales que atraviesan el cuerpo de
lo que estamos hablando de acceso a la
cultura tiene el mismo reconocimiento y
el mismo respeto defender el territorio
que el territorio expropiado y material
de este acceso fundamental que nos da
una identidad clave y precisa de lo que
significa ser no persona no mexicano no
guerrerense sino persona esa parte de la
dignidad humana es fundamental y ahí es
donde radica también la cooperación que
se puede realizar no solamente desde
nosotros que nos dedicamos a
transformarlo a partir de procesos
jurídicos y tediosos sino a las formas
de organización comunitaria que son las
únicas que durante muchísimos años han
brindado la posibilidad de hacer este
acceso que me llega mucho esta parte de
fundir la defensa no solamente el
territorio sino de la cultura a partir
del cuerpo la lengua y nuestra tierra
porque va muy muy ligado con los
derechos humanos y con la historia
propia que construimos no son espacios
exclusivos para una alta cultura no son
espacios exclusivos y sacralizados donde
vamos a aprender e iluminarlo
la verdadera forma de acceso es ponerlos
a la disposición de todas y todas las
personas que puedan acceder a estos
desde las plazas públicas desde los
parques desde las colonias populares
desde todos estos espacios donde la
obligación no sea sólo del estado sino
sea en conjunto esa es la mayor carga de
responsabilidad que tenemos como
ciudadanas y como ciudadanos hacernos
responsable de la preservación de
derechos fundamentales como es este que
va ligado a la dignidad humana a la
integridad de la vida y algo muy
importante a la atención de la salud
emocional que es fundamental en estos
momentos y pública ese esa tarea de
ciudadanizar las políticas culturales
que parece que solamente son privativas
a órganos como el instituto nacional
electoral o los propios partidos
políticos donde si hay recursos de sobra
para poder ejecutarlos es en la materia
cultural donde se debe invertir porque
porque es un medio idóneo también para
alcanzar un estado no solamente
democrático
no solamente democrático en el discurso
sino un estado de bienestar social y
humano que eso es lo más importante
maría andrea villarreal al trasladar las
prensas en donde se editaron los números
de aquel legendario periódico 'el y el
en regeneración desde el exilio decía
que ellas comenzaron la lucha
emancipatoria y que ya vendrían otras a
continuarla y tenía razón porque aquí
estamos continuando
[Música]